parents on the hunt for not only
supplies but clothing as well with
rising prices everyone could all use a
deal right now jeremy j ford shares
where to find some back to school
thrifting bargains
[Music]
it's discount season across southern
nevada where shoppers are hitting some
of the best retail stores across the
valley to get some
of the best deals i am always looking
for a good deal
i
like to save a buck here or there if i
if i can
lauren knows the stores in the valley
besides discount retailers like ross and
tj maxx she also hits thrift stores most
things i
wear and own are from goodwill with
inflation running high low and middle
income families are looking to stretch a
dollar when it comes to back to school
supplies and clothing i asked followers
on facebook where they're getting deals
kohl's was a top talker and many also
said target and walmart were slashing
prices and always deals at burlington
and marshalls brian stewart is the vp of
marketing for goodwill he says shopping
at thrift stores has an added value the
dollars that are generated through sales
of items here at goodwill fund our
programs to help people train for jobs
and thriving careers
a reason why lawrence says in today's
economy there are many creative ways to
save repurpose your clothes discount
shopping here at goodwill there's other
thrift stores locally owned buy from
people who are making their clothes
themselves jeremy j ford live local now